-We're about to play
"Secret Ingredient."
Now, here's how it works.
We're each gonna be served
a gourmet three-course meal,
but each dish contains
one unusual secret ingredient.
-Uh-huh.
-And it's and our job
to figure out
what that ingredient is.
All I know is that I have this
next to my chair.
So...
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, I got one, too.
-Oh, you got one -- okay, good.
So I have a feeling
some of these
are gonna be interesting.
All right.
Quest, be nice to me, please.
Why are you smiling like that?
-I didn't prepare this.
I'm just reading.
-Yeah, I know.
[ Laughter ]
-Anyway...
-Look how happy you are.
Look how happy --
Quest, what is the first course?
-Thank you, Jimmy.
To start, we have a refreshing
piña colada with blended
organic coconut cream,
fresh pineapple,
and a splash of lime juice,
garnished with
a maraschino cherry.
But can you guess
the secret ingredient?
Bon appétit.
Hit it.
-This is beautiful.
-All right.
-Cheers.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-[ Laughing ]
Oh, yeah!
Oh, oh, whoa!
-Ha! Whoo!
-Whoo!
-I mean, we all know what it is.
-Write your -- no, hell no.
Write your answers down,
gentlemen.
-No, we definitely
know what it is.
-Oh, okay.
-Okay.
We're gonna start with Rhett.
Can you guess
what the secret ingredient was?
-I believe...
-Yeah.
-...it was...wasabi?
[ Buzzer ]
-That is incorrect.
[ Sad tuba ]
James Fallon,
what is the secret ingredient?
-Horseradish.
-Oh.
-That is incorrect.
[ Buzzer ]
-What?
-All right. Link,
what is the secret ingredient?
-What about wasab-E?
[ Buzzer ]
-Ah, wasab-E!
Okay, no.
The correct answer
was yellowtail sashimi.
-Oh. Yeah, but they
got some wasabi on that.
-Yeah.
-Some wasabi in there!
-They got some wasabi on that.
-Hey, I'm just going
with the judges.
All right, judges.
Is that the same thing?
[ Buzzer ]
All right, see?
-It was yellowtail sashimi.
-That is the most
demoralizing sound in the world.
All right.
-All right.
Speaking of seafood --
-No!
Why are we speaking of seafood?
-Let's speak more of seafood.
Yes.
Speaking of seafood,
for our next course,
we have a crab cake
made with jumbo lump crab meat
from Maryland.
All right?
-Oh.
-Seasoned with a medley
of spices.
-Maryland's really gonna
push me over the edge?
-Yes, it came direct from --
-Oh! No, what is this?
I don't like creamy stuff.
[ Laughter ]
-All right.
Look, it's with herbs and spices
and pan-fried
until golden brown.
-Yeah, I don't like it.
-But, Jimmy...
-I don't like it.
[ Laughter ]
-...can you guess
the secret ingredient?
-I'm just gonna guess
without eating it.
-Hit it.
-You got to eat it.
-We might do this right, though.
I mean, a little lemon --
-Mm, that's right,
put that lemon on there.
Yeah.
Dig deep.
-Uh, I don't like, uh...
All right.
I don't like creamy stuff.
[ Laughter ]
-It's not bad.
It's not bad.
-Okay. All right.
-It's not good either, though.
-Taste some more.
All right, all right, all right.
You got to
write your answers down.
♪♪
-Tastes like a crab cake.
-Oh.
-Yeah, but that wasn't bad
at all.
-There's something
hidden in there that --
-Yeah, there is.
-Oh, yeah.
Something just hit me on
the end there, maybe.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
All right, so, Rhett,
we'll start with you.
Can you guess
what the secret ingredient was?
-Um, I think it might be
chocolate, y'all.
Yeah.
-Judges, what do you say?
[ Buzzer ]
Nope.
[ Sad tuba ]
-Idiot!
-Jimmy.
-You hear that?
-What is the secret ingredient?
-I'm gonna say
it's a breakfast cereal.
I'm think I'll say
it's Corn Cones.
[ Laughter ]
[ Buzzer ]
[ Sad tuba ]
-You know what?
-Little throwback.
-It's not that...
but I'll allow it, so...
-Wow.
-Anyway, Link,
what is the correct answer?
-I tasted some sweetness
in there.
I feel a little prune action.
[ Laughter ]
[ Buzzer ]
[ Sad tuba ]
-Aw!
-That's not a bad guess.
I was tasting something kind of,
like, sugary.
-You were near it.
It was actually cookie dough.
-Cookie dough?
-There's still chocolate in it!
-Cookie --
[ Laughter ]
-Hey, dawg, talk to the --
talk to the judges.
-Half a point?
-You got to go --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I think we give him
half a point.
[ Ding! ]
-I think -- yeah.
-Half a point.
-Oh, yeah, half a point.
-You have half a point.
You're in the lead.
You're guessing
the right things.
-All right. Let's get down
to our last course.
All right, so the meal is not
complete without dessert.
And tonight,
we have a cinnamon roll.
-Mm.
-Great.
-Made from puffy brioche dough.
-Oh, puffy, huh.
-Rolled with cinnamon spices
and with melted butter.
-Okay. You're talking about
a cinnamon roll.
-Yeah.
Topped with vanilla sugar.
But can you -- can you guess
what the secret ingredient is?
-Now, I don't like creamy stuff.
Do I have to try that?
-You got to get -- the best part
of a cinnamon roll is the heart.
-Yeah.
-You gotta de-heart it.
[ Laughter ]
You want to excise that heart,
Jimmy.
-I don't --
-Like that.
-I don't like --
I don't like creamy stuff,
so I'm not gonna
try that creamy stuff.
-That's how you kill
a cinnamon roll.
-You never had
a cinnamon roll before, Jimmy?
-Uh, yeah.
-It's great, Jimmy!
Get in there!
-Wait, so your anti-cream thing
is also with...
-I don't like --
-Will you just --
Go ahead, man.
Come on.
-No, I can't do it.
I can't.
-Just do it!
-It's great, Jimmy.
-I can't do it. I don't like
creamy mayonnaise, mustard.
Like, no, I can't do it.
-Do it! Do it!
-It's not mayonnaise.
It's not mustard.
-Come on.
-I don't like it.
[ Audience chanting "Jimmy!" ]
-What is that?
[ Applause ]
♪♪
-[ Laughs ]
Oh!
[ Sad tuba ]
-All right, Rhett?
[ Trash can bangs ]
Now remember,
this is worth 10,000 points.
-Oh, yeah.
-Oh, really?
-Yeah.
It's worth 10,000 points.
-I'm very confident
in this answer.
I believe the secret ingredient
was love.
[ Laughter ]
[ Sad tuba ]
[ Buzzer ]
-No.
-You say prunes again?
-I was -- I was not
the secret ingredient.
Jimmy.
-Yeah?
-What is the secret ingredient?
-It was disgusting.
It was awful
and cruel and I just -- gosh.
I'm so mad.
But I'm gonna say toothpaste?
[ Buzzer ]
[ Sad tuba ]
-That'd have been good, though.
-Thank you.
-No. Link?
-It had a sourness to it.
-Yeah, it had a sourness to it.
That's why I said lemon.
[ Buzzer ]
[ Sad tuba ]
Lemon.
-Sometimes love is sour.
[ Laughter ]
-No --
-Love goes bad.
-Is this real?
Can I have this?
Or is this, like, dog urine
or something like that?
[ Laughter ]
-So, the answer was steak sauce.
-Oh.
-Oh, I can smell it!
Got to smell the hole.
-No, I'm good, dawg.
I'm good.
-Steak sauce.
All right.
Thanks for Rhett and Link.
Check out "Inside Eats
with Rhett & Link,"
airing Sundays at 10:30 p.m.
on the Food Network.